parce que les de travailler votre qui
savent pas il y en aura un dans une
encre à me retrouver dans quelques
minutes de temps peut être glissé les
cadeaux sous le sapin
tiens pourquoi pas ça peut être sympa ça
peut être un cadeau lecture on l'a
compris ce matin typhaine oui tant qu'à
faire
puis tout à l'heure nous étions en haute
saône on va y rester je vais vous parler
d'un livre publié par une petite maison
d'édition justement qui s'appelle
chocolat jeunesse et qui est basée à
brézillet c'est un livre qui s'appelle
la clé d'or adapté d'un conte de grimm
et qui a été écrit et illustré par
joseph vernon qui est aussi justement
franc comtois alors je ne sais pas si
vous connaissez ce conte c'est
l'histoire d'un jeune garçon qui part
dans la forêt couper du bois dans la
neige
alors voilà et qui trouve une clé d'or
alors évidemment le lecteur se demande
ce qu'il va en faire
et comme le jeune garçon se demande ce
que cette clé peut bien ouvrir alors
l'album évidemment parle de ça de la
quête de du coffre ou de la porte qui va
pouvoir être ouverte par cette clé est
justement c'est un petit album d'
aventure puisque vous le voyez il va
escalader il va marcher dans la neige et
dans la forêt pour essayer de trouver ce
qui va bien pouvoir être ouvert cette
clé est donc le lecteur se demande ce
qu'il va devenir riche grâce à cette clé
est ce qu il prend des risques inutiles
c'est donc un petit album d' aventure
voilà qui peuvent s'adresser au plus
petit bain dès 4 ans et vous le voyez
moi j'ai bien aimé le format parce que
c'est un très long livre et les couleurs
puisque tout est en verre en marron ça
se passe dans la neige c'est automnale
je me suis dit que c'était un album
parfait pour cet hiver
en plus c'est 100% franche-comté parfait
c'est notre région donc nous on aime clé
du bonheur qu'elle la réussite
prenez pas la clé des champs tout de
suite parce que j'ai besoin d'une autre
une autre idée de cadeau parce qu'il ya
pas que des tout-petits qu'il faut
regretter pour noël à 21 dodo de noël
dites-moi est-ce qu'on peut mettre un
deuxième cadeau sous le sapin
oui un cadeau un petit peu fantastique
aussi vous savez quel est l'animal
préféré des enfants
alors moi je dirais
comme ça pas quelque chose de plutôt
gentil qu'est ce que vous pensez à quoi
vous anaïs chien un chien mais n'ont pas
du tout la licorne voyons comme j'aimais
bien sûr veilleurs la dernière ne lance
un livre de gilles baume et christophe
merlin publié par gautier languereau
alors c'est plutôt une sorte de grimoire
qui se transmettrait de génération en
génération et justement l'héroïne
l'ialie découvre grâce à ce grimoire que
sa famille forme une sorte de
confédération de confréries de
protecteur de licorne qui étudie les
lits comme de génération en génération
vous le voyez qu'il ré de 220 sud voilà
qui dresse des dessins comme ça pour les
répertorier pour répertorier leur mode
de vie leur implantation et quand elle
découvre ça elle fait dit que c'est
fantastique d'appartenir à sept familles
malheureusement figurez-vous que l'élu
comme ont presque disparu
or l'homme en piette sur leur mode de
vie
donc c'est une petite réflexion quand
même un rien écologique sur notre place
dans le monde
mais c'est surtout magnifiquement
illustré ça fera rêver tous les enfants
à partir d'un collège au beau parcours
de cet homme va dire parce qu'il ya
quand même beaucoup de textes et
beaucoup de schémas donc il faut quand
même se retrouver dans ce grimoire on a
un autre livre qui est un porte ouverte
finalement sur un autre univers un
univers un petit peu particulier
alors cette fois ci c'est peut-être pour
les plus de 10 ans oui on va dire ça
parce que c'est quand même un roman
assez conséquent ça s'appelle les livres
des maîtres farmer et ça ira bien dans
toutes les bibliothèques puisque ça
parle de livres c'est un roman de
bridget police publié chez lattès et
l'histoire c'est l'histoire d'un jeune
garçon qui s'appelle émettent qui
appartient justement à une famille de
fermiers comme son nom l'indiqué parle
un peu anglais et qui tombe malade d'une
fièvre un petit peu bizarre on ne sait
pas trop de quoi il s'agit un jour il
reçoit une lettre de serre est dit qu
est une femme en livrera qu'est ce que
c'est un ans livreur
c'est quelqu'un qui fabrique des livres
voilà des magnifiques livres pour
enfermer les souvenirs alors c'est les
souvenirs dont on veut se débarrasser
figurez vous continentaux nous fait
quelque chose de pas terrible qui nous
est arrivé quelque chose d'un peu
particulier on veut les oublier
mais ça ne disparaît pas on les enferme
dans un livre et cette série dit que lui
propose de devenir son apprenti
alors il ya toute une réflexion autour
d'eux faut-il faire des livres un peu
particulier les ains livreurs sont ils
des sorciers c'est passionnant je vous
le conseille c'est très beau c'est super
anaïs govou qui est responsable de la
bibliothèque gaspard mange à bonn je me
sentais très attentif comment vous
choisissez les livres pour les enfants
comité dans la bibliothèque
alors on essaie forcément c'est notre
travail de choisir les livres qui ont
une plus value culturel et qui vont
rester ainsi possible de ne pas ne pas
se soumettre aux effets de mode et
essayer de trouver des ouvrages qui sont
qui nous apparaissent comme riche que ce
soit au niveau des illustrations que du
texte qui transmettent des pas parler
des grandes valeurs forcément mais mais
des choses intéressantes pour que les
enfants grandissent et comprennent la
société dans laquelle ils vivent et puis
on va aussi essayer de valoriser les
petites et les petites maisons d'édition
ont fait seulement bien que vous me
disais c'est parce que vous êtes
peut-être des auteurs de la région n'ont
alors dans la région des auteurs de la
région bien sûr on a par exemple tous
les ouvrages de fred bernard par exemple
qui habite à côté de beaune
et qui conserve à la bibliothèque parce
que thibaut vernon ça vous dit quelque
chose
oui alors on en a aussi ça tombe bien
parce que je crois que c'est la dernière
sélection livré ses derniers livres
c'est de thibaut vernon mais vers mot
pardon tu es né à dijon
ça s'appelle fraternité etc aux éditions
sarbacane et ça a été distingué par une
mention spéciale au prix vendredi parce
que c'est un roman passionnant qui mêle
des références actuelles
et puis un esprit de cape et d'épée
alors l'histoire je vous la raconte
brièvement c est repéré un jeune un
jeune lycéen qui est un peu un looser
vous voyez qui se fait un peu persécutés
et puis lui ont alors cessé l'auteur et
puis alors figurez-vous que son truc
c'est chaque vendredi de s'évader dans
la lande dans le devon en angleterre
et puis de déterrer une épée et de se
prendre pour un mousquetaire alors ça va
devenir une obsession pour lui vraiment
je vous le conseille seulement c'est à
partir de 14 ans parce que c'est un
livre un peu conséquent c'est
magnifiquement écrit parce que ça mail
de la prose et des verts est vraiment
c'est un super roman à mettre entre les
mains de tous les jeunes de 14 ans ça se
lit très bien voilà je voulais parfait
il pas rien pour les difficultés ni
communication entre frères et soeurs
c'est bien ça non oui c'est pas mal et
c'est bien ça il ya un vrai souffle
épique
c'est une sorte de cyrano moderne
tébessa marie le contemporain avec
l'internaute le harcèlement scolaire
j'en passe et j'en oublie et puis les
problèmes de fratries parfois qui
peuvent exister et en plus c'est de la
région une excision donc thibault vernon
et y clin d'oeil très bien merci
allez merci pour cette sélection a
retrouvé aussi sur le